If you can find a laugh,
you'll find ease.
Laugh at everything.
“Kevin, What if I'm not funny?
I don't know what to do.”
That's what I want to show you.
This class is about how I built my career,
relationships and life,
by using comedy
and how you can to.
D*mn, I'm pretty dope.
My biggest advice
to anybody giving any type of speech,
your speech has to have levels.
My hand
movements, my voice.
When I choose to elevate my voice
versus when I get a little softer.
It’s all a performance to some degree.
What I think that humor does,
is soften whoever is on the other side
to possibly talk to you more.
Interviewer: It sounds like
self-deprecation is like a...
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Use words
that I understand.
I don't know what that means.
Did you just call me dumb?
Interviewer:
No, you’re just playing dumb.
No, but you see how I did that?
See, I broke it up.
Now you got the laugh.
You’re probably asking yourself,
“Why are you being so generous
with all this information
and strategies that you’ve built
to make yourself so successful?”
“Why, Kevin? Why?”
I want you to
know that comedy
isn’t just about stand-up.
It's a life skill.
My name is Kevin Hart,
and this is MasterClass.